évidemment j'aurais préféré que
dominique bailly soit élu avec nous mais
personne dans le nord n'a fait plus que
deux sénateurs il ya une répartition
presque parfaite
des voix c'est un mode de scrutin qui a
autorisé cette répartition
dont acte j'ai fait je crois une belle
campagne avec mes colistiers je souhaite
vraiment saluer le travail aussi de
dominique bailly nous sommes arrivés à
12 voix près juste derrière valérie
létard malgré les pertes en ville que
nous avons connu depuis 2014 donc c'est
un bon score
bien sûr on espère toujours faire mieux
on a fait le maximum dans cette campagne
je suis très heureux déjà d'avoir en
taule mais le même nombre de sénateurs
que mes collègues
justement c'est la surprise pas de prime
pour voilà les grands partis qui elles
sont et qui ont présenté des listes mais
voilà on éparpillement aujourd'hui
qu'elle commence vous analysé ce
résultat il y avait un choix important
dans le nord 12 listes différentes cinq
listes à droite deux listes se réclamant
dans marche une liste communiste une
liste social-démocrate que j'ai
l'honneur de mener une liste verte donc
tout cela a permis un choix très
important pour les 5865 grands électeurs
et ils ont profité de ce choix qui leur
étaient offertes et malgré l avance que
nous avons avec valérie létard sur les
autres listes eh bien nous ne ferons pas
plus que deux sénateurs par le mode de
scrutin c'est une déception pour le ps
qui d'autant plus bien ce resort se
renforcer à paris avec quatre élues
voilà c'est aussi l'amertume ici dans le
match espagne amertume je suis très
content que nos amis parisiens passent
quatre sièges
on a failli passer un troisième sûrement
à quelques voix ce qui aurait été un
très grand succès voilà aucune liste ne
fait plus de deux sièges dans le nord il
faut en prendre acte et continuer à
travailler parce qu'on attend notre
objectif c'est de servir nos territoires
et puis de défendre aussi les locaux
face aux menaces qui pèsent sur eux et
qu'ils se sont déclarés pendant l'été en
matière notamment de moyens humains et
moyens financiers dernier moyen d'années
en question sur la présidence du groupe
ps au sénat
quel est votre votre option qu'est-ce
que qu'est ce que vous défendez comme
option on est nous réunirons bien sûr ou
demain ou après demain ou plus tard il
des candidatures didier guillaume a été
un excellent président il faut le
reconnaître histoire à d'autres
signatures nous ne verrons bien ce sera
une délibération collective laisser le
temps au temps